hi guys before we get started i just
wanted to let you guys know that my next
graphic novel the lie behind the star is
in the works it's a science fiction
story with elements of cosmic horror and
mystery i've been working really hard to
craft this story and the campaign begins
february 2020 on indiegogo you can click
the link in the description for more
information and to join the email
mailing list so you know exactly when it
launches
also just a heads up the audiobook
version of my first graphic novel tadaya
is now available
when you get the audiobook you'll get
two versions of fully scored audio drama
with music and sound effects and one
with just my voice whichever is your
preference in exchange for our gifts
which have allowed you to rise up from
poverty granted you wealth and power and
respect we asked but one thing
a simple thing really
we require your eldest daughter
i don't know if all of you noticed but i
never do sponsored content on this
channel so by supporting my comics you
can really help out
[Music]
hi guys it's quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the youtube algorithm
really notices me
[Music]
my favorite thing about the dune series
is how it points out the dramatic shifts
that take place in the human collected
unconscious over millennia
like the evolution of how the worm is
viewed in the first book the worm
represents an unstoppable force of
nature the worm is arrakis arrakis is
the worm it is the living and physical
embodiment of the desert itself
in fremont culture the worm is god
because he keeps the desert for his
people
shaihalud guards the entrance into their
secret realm
the worm is exalted in fremen society
enormous deadly rageful yet protective
and graceful
all of this changes after book four god
emperor of dune
paul etradies's son leto the second took
the image of the worm and twisted it
by the time of god emperor of dune
arrakis is no longer desert the worms
have long gone
only the worm god emperor remains
arrakis had been terraformed over the
last 3 500 years and now is essentially
a paradise world in terms of climate
lato had given humanity a false sense of
stability especially on arrakis and this
stability and serenity had been enforced
brutally
but he had always known that it would
eventually end
the desert and the worms would return
but something would be different this
time the worms would be different as
each one would have a piece of his own
consciousness living inside them he did
this full well knowing what the
consequences would be
knowing how it would change the
perception of the worms in the eyes of
the new desert dwellers of arrakis
but also knowing that there was no
better route to take
within 300 years the sand worm once more
will reign here
it will be a new kind of sandworm i
promise you
how is that lord
it will have animal awareness
and a new cunning
the spice will be more dangerous to seek
and far more perilous to keep
maneo had looked up at the cavern's
rocky ceiling his imagination probing
through the rock to the surface
everything desert again lord
watercourses will fill with sand
crops will be choked and killed
trees will be covered by great moving
dunes
the sand depth will spread until
until a subtle signal is heard in the
barren lands
what signal lord
the signal for the next cycle
the coming of the maker
the coming of shai halud
will that be you lord yes the great sand
worm of dune will rise once more from
the deeps this land will be again the
domain of spice and worm but what of the
people lord
all the people many will die food plants
and the abundant growth of this land
will be parched
without nourishment
meat animals will die
will everyone go hungry lord under
nourishment and the old diseases will
stalk the land
while only the hardiest live
the hardiest and most brutal must that
be lord
the alternative is worse
the new worms that would eventually
inhabit the new deserts would each be
guided in some way by the moat of latos
being within them
and to the desert dwellers it would no
longer be a protector or a guardian but
an oppressor a destroyer this is very
much the perspective of the character
shiana who eventually learned that she
had the ability to control the desert
worms by the time of shianna there had
been a crucial shift
shai halud whose name meant something to
the effect of old father of the desert
or grandfather of the desert once
exalted
now became
chaitan
a word which literally means satan
god became the devil
i've actually discussed this before in
this video here
and there's also what i think is an
interesting literary comparison that i
make between a scene in heretics of dune
and a scene in dante's divine comedy
you can check that out if you want to
learn more about that
now of course if you are familiar with
the evolution of myths then you know
that myths are often adopted and altered
to serve new functions in new
mythological structures kind of like how
christians adopted the imagery of the
god baphomet to represent the devil one
culture's god is another culture's devil
how myths are regarded by individuals
and by society is entirely due to the
variables which have contributed to the
formation and development of that
society when the worm protects you it is
god when the worm destroys you it is
satan
frank herbert was obviously very
interested in the concept of current
events being contextualized within the
context of the long view of history
all important events become mythologized
eventually the actual event ends up
mattering way less than the myth itself
let's talk about how lato the second in
particular is viewed historically and
mythologically versus who he truly was
though some in the imperium such as the
dlalaksu and the priest of raqqas have
created mythology centering the god
emperor in some aspect at least as a
true deity most in the imperium remember
him as the tyrant and by this point in
time more than 1500 years following his
death many have fled the imperium never
to be seen again later the second was
the most evil ruler who ever lived in
terms of the suffering he caused
but the pro-lato argument here is that
in part due to the universe
paul
through his actions set up and in part
due to the nature of humanity to fall in
line behind charismatic leaders
lato's evil was necessary in order to
help humanity avoid falling victim to
the same kind of evil in the future
lato did not act out of malevolence in
fact he acted out of love for all of
humanity but for the sake of love he
committed acts of evil
and this of course gets back to the
reason why there are no heroes in dune
heroes are myths
there are no heroes in dune at least not
in the indefinite sense the dune series
understands that being a hero is not a
trait one possesses but a fleeting
transitory experience that one embodies
for a period of time
the same for the concept of goodness or
greatness this goes back to the saying
die a hero or live long enough to see
yourself become a villain you can be a
hero for time but you could never at all
times behave heroically greatness is an
interesting example and like the state
of being heroic it is also transitory
one can achieve greatness at some point
but without acknowledging that greatness
is fleeting one can easily fall victim
to one's own pretensions the state of
being great can convince one that
greatness is a static trait rather than
something utterly transient my favorite
quote on this is
the person who experiences greatness
must have a feeling for the myth he is
in he must reflect what is projected
upon him he must have a strong sense of
the sardonic
this is what uncouples him from the
belief in his own pretensions the
sardonic is all that permits him to move
within himself without this quality even
occasional greatness will destroy a man
frank herbert is saying that the most
dangerous thing
that a person who experiences transitory
greatness can do is buy into their own
mythology
just because you are at one time great
does it mean at all times you will be
great herbert understood that this was
something that affected many people
buying into your own myth leaves you
unable to evaluate your shortcomings and
acknowledge your wrongs
obviously frank herbert saw this as a
problem mainly plaguing those in power
and of course this fact makes it far
more dangerous a leader who does not
have a sense of who they are beyond
their own myth is a danger to the
society they are attempting to govern
now let's talk about why the actions of
paul atreides and his son had such an
impact in the first place besides the
fact that they were prescient the thing
you have to understand about arrakis is
that the planet itself is a wasteland
and yet without it the imperium could
not function
paula trady's eventual impact on the
imperium is magnified
by the fact that house atreides went to
dune
everyone knows that arrakis is the only
place in the known universe where spice
can be found spice production is
directly tied to the life cycle of the
great worms spice is essential to space
travel
therefore arrakis is central but this is
not all the reason paul's impact is
magnified simply by the fact that he is
on arrakis is due to the fact that since
arrakis is central to the imperium any
events taking place on arrakis have the
potential to dramatically influence the
imperium as a whole
herbert is calling out that the reliance
on spice to sustain the empire is
perilous because the actions of a few on
one world could affect the entire
imperium at the heart is a critique of
centralized governments in a specific
sense
when a populace grows to a certain size
a centralized ruling structure will have
more and more difficulty justifying its
hierarchy what gives one world the right
to rule 100 others frank herbert is
pointing out the unjustness of this but
also its danger by book four the entire
imperium is fiercely ruled and
suppressed under one ruler under one
world when this ruling structure
eventually falls the result is
devastating this is also the conceit of
asimov's foundation which herbert draws
many of these concepts from
science fiction authors have created
these cataclysmic scenarios not only as
entertainment but also to warn us of the
potential dark places humanity could be
headed for
dune is obviously a heavily
philosophical book there's nothing quite
like it i hope you've enjoyed this video
if you want to learn more about dune or
some other awesome sci-fi books
check out my channel thanks guys
[Music]
[Music]
you